so remember in the cold open we have the
a and the B story the a story line here
can le bring the big villains to justice
what's he doing here in the cold opening
if you guys are following on please do
please be watching this while I give you
this lecture it's gonna be so much
better for you if you can I wish I could
show it to you um he's remember I told
you a hero in a television pilot is
often misusing his superpower at the
beginning of the show and Elliott is
misusing his superpower to be in a show
how well he's working for a corporation
that actually helps the villain that's a
misuse what's his superpower he's an
amazing computer hacker right but she's
misusing it at the beginning and in this
a storyline in the cold open he's also
though and the reason we love him so
much
is he's bringing one villain to justice
not the big villain but a small villain
a pedophile in a coffee shop and as he
does this he brings all of his technical
knowledge to bear and he's busted this
pedophile who has a ring of coffee shops
but he's got this this pedophile porn
ring and he busts him but as he says he
does so he says his core wound he tells
the pedophile you know what I sympathize
with you I'm different too here's this
poor wound I don't know how to talk to
people
Elliott says my dad was the only one I
could talk to he's dead what does that
give us it gives us his core wound it
makes us empathize with this weird weird
God because we're all weird right we
want to know our humors are weird and
story because it means they're real and
his dad died why it's very important a
corporation killed him
poisoned him his dad worked with
pollution and then Elliott says the
corporation is fine my dad is dead this
is the bleeding wound that's gonna tie
right in with our a storyline fighting a
corporation that has so much power that
they can hurt people and continue to be
in violent this is a beautiful way that
s Mel
this story together now the pedophile
tries to pay him off but he won't Elliot
says I don't care about money I got
another surprise and then they bust him
and that's the end of the cold open now
guys we're not gonna have time today to
talk about the four acts structure in
television but it's important you know
what it is it's seven different beats
per act the a storyline has 15 to 16 of
these beats the B has seven to eight the
C has three to four and the D is why do
I talk about this oh I'm not really
gonna talk about it because you need to
look at my television lecture or
somebody else's television lecture to
make you understand that every act every
hour-long drama has this same structure
no matter how crazy you are
and how much you want to break the rules
the reason it's there is to entertain
the audience in a rhythm like a pop song
has a bridge a chorus a verse even the
craziest ones right they all do because
it entertains the audience so we're not
gonna talk about that all now but you
need to understand that's true and each
beat has a hero and antagonist and a
fight inside the beat a beat is two or
three minutes long it is a single
dramatic act and there's 28 of them in
eight hour long television show and in
mr. robot there is two beats in the cold
open one of the beats is this big fight
between Elliot and this pedophile and
it's resolved at the end of the beat
it's as if you ate 24 or 28 little
canapes as opposed to one giant entree
it entertains you now remember these
patterns are all to keep the audience
entertained so we've opened on the a and
the B and by the way if you're looking
at this and viewing it you'll see mr.
robot Christian Slater right there you
know on the subway at the beginning
he's the mentor he's a shape-shifter
which means are gonna talk about that in
a minute
mentors heal heroes car loans that's
what they're for and that's what he's
gonna start doing now in television they
don't heal completely but they heal a
little bit and remember we have three
pots and a mystery filler I know I'm
talking a lot about the
I know it's confusing you can watch this
several times the plot in a mystery
thriller it's really critical is that
there's an emotional change in the hero
throughout the story that helps him
solve the crime that's the key and all
great mysteries fillers whether it's
movies or television so Eliot is in the
beginning of act 1 and we start with our
a storyline usually in act 1 Ellie is on
that subway and the a story question is
can he beat the villains and we also see
mr. robot who says it's an exciting time
to be in the world today uh it's
Christian Slater we kind of see him out
of the corner whoa whoa who's that guy
and that's all we see of him now because
remember in a mystery thriller things
are hidden at first they only pop up a
little bit now Elliott tells us I'm only
a vigilante Hocker by day by night and
during the day I work for a company that
is actually evil interesting huh and we
see him go to his office and we see now
the B storyline come in because his
friend Angela who he's not sleeping with
but has been friends since he's a
childhood is arguing with their boss now
this is really important because Angela
is a girl in a man's world she's a woman
in a man's world and she's being
condescended to the boss is sexist
towards her and we're gonna see that
that's critical in this story and it's
part of what makes this story so
appealing to 20-somethings because so
many women in the workplace are
experiencing just this right now and
it's also gonna make us like Elliot cuz
he's gonna help her but she's gonna
teach him how cuz he screws it up at the
beginning when we first see her she's
telling her boss that she can handle the
problem than the boss is saying no you
can't so what is our B story here
remember it's can Elliot bond with
Angela if he can you'll have an
emotional change that will help him
solve the crime can by the way this is a
buddy relationship in general Elliot and
if you look at my lectures on universe
of story you'll see whether it's a buddy
or a love story usually one of the
two-part
in this relationship is teaching the
other one how to be confident and the
other was teaching the other one how to
be caring these are lakhs they have that
form the chemical reaction that we're
gonna want to want to watch whether it's
the notebook or Titanic or a cop buddy
movie this is usually the dynamic and in
this story it is as well because Elliott
lacks what do you think caring he's got
a little Asperger's and Angela lacks
confidence so when we first see them
we're seeing her try to justify to the
boss that she can handle the situation
and the boss shrugging it off and saying
you can't handle it now suddenly we get
what's coming up to be inciting incident
the boss says to Elliot we were hacked
again or the company we weak for ich or
the big company the evil villain the
real villains in our real crime pod they
were hacked last night someone broke in
Elliot's boss is freaked out it's their
biggest client a corporation and Elliot
is the guy who's gonna help rescue that
remember he's misusing his super power
he doesn't want to do it he's working
for a company that is actually helping a
villain so angela is supposed to be in
charge in this situation but she's not
cuz she's a woman she's shoved aside she
lacks confidence and she lets them do it
to her what's her core wound cuz that's
important to her core wound is she's not
powerful she's letting men tell her
she's not powerful she's going to have a
change in this story - guys this is a
brilliant story SML is a brilliant
creator so much is going on here when
you watch this story you will see Angela
lacks the confidence she can do this job
she wants Elliot now the next thing we
see is her say to him she takes him
aside hey Elliot why didn't you come to
my party last night
guys what storyline is that that's the B
storyline can Elliot bond with Angela
emotionally now Angela is reflecting
to him as a good buddy what he needs to
learn Eliot you must bond emotionally
with people and notice what Eliot says
to her uh yeah I'm sorry I couldn't make
it and she says you promised me you
would try she's trying to help him do
what learn to care this is a classic
relationship dynamic now we go to the
deep lot which often happens on the
first act and if you want to break down
of all these act structures go to my
television collection on university of
story I have all of this broken down and
it's critical that you understand this
and I don't understand why most people
don't do this in their books but it's
why I do it there's another plot here
the D plot will Elliott save his shrink
from her evil con artist boyfriend now
we see that she's a psychologist but
here's what's interesting about Elliott
and any character when you first see a
character you have his wound now what if
you're wounded as a person what do you
know what's your first of all ask
yourself what's your biggest wound okay
emotionally what's your biggest
embarrassment now what have you done to
compensate for that in your life okay
you